let's go into this unification
uh the battle against the contradictions
and the tensions between the theories of
physics what is quantum gravity maybe
what is the standard model of physics
what is quantum mechanics what is
general relativity what's quantum
gravity
uh what are all the different
unification efforts
okay so again five questions yeah
it's a theory that describes
everything with astonishing accuracy
it's the most
accurate theory in the history of human
thought
Theory and experiment have been
successfully compared to 16 decimal
place
we have that stenciled on the door where
where I work you know it's a it's an
amazing it's an amazing feat of the
human mind
it describes
um the electromagnetic interaction
unifies the electromagnetic interaction
with the so-called weak interaction
which
you need some good tools to even view
the weak interaction and then there's
the strong interaction
which binds the quarks into protons
and the forces between them are mediated
by something called Yang Mills Theory
which is a a beautiful mathematical
generalization of electromagnetism
in which the analogs of the photons
insert themselves carry charge
and
um so this uh the final piece of this
of the standard model everything in the
standard model has been observed and
it's properties have been measured the
final particle to be observed was the
Higgs particle
served like a over a decade ago a Higgs
is already a decade ago I I think it is
yeah wow time flies but you better check
me on that yeah it's it's true but so
much fun has been happening it's so much
fun it's been happening and so that's
all
um
that's that's all pretty well understood
there's some things that miter might not
around the edges of that you know Dark
Matter neutrino masses
some sort of
fine points or things we
haven't quite measured perfectly and so
on but it's largely a very complete
uh complete Theory and we don't
expect
anything very new
conceptually
in the completion of that anything
contradictory but I'm new because can't
you think contradictory yeah I'll have
some wild questions uh for you on that
front but yeah anything that yeah
because there's no gaps it's so accurate
so precise in its predictions it's hard
to imagine something yeah yeah yeah
and it was all based on something called
let me not explain what it is let me
just throw out the buzzword
renormalizable quantum field Theory they
all fall in the category of
renormalizable quantum field Theory I'm
going to throw to that at a bar later to
impress
impress the girls
good luck thank you
all right so uh they all they all fall
under that rubric gravity will not will
not will not put that suit on
so the force of gravity
Cannot Be Tamed by the same
renormalizable Quantum field Theory to
which the all the other forces
so eagerly submitted what is the effort
of quantum gravity what are the
different efforts to um
to have these two dance together
effectively to try to unify uh the
standard model and um and general
relativity any kind of model of gravity
sort of the one fully uh consistent
model that we have
that reconciles
that it it would that sort of tames
gravity and reconciles it with quantum
mechanics
uh is string theory and its cousins and
we don't know what or if in any sense
String Theory describes the world the
physical world
but we do know that it
um
is a consistent
reconciliation of quantum mechanics and
general relativity and moreover one
which
um
which is able to incorporate
particles and forces like the ones we
see around us so
it hasn't been ruled out as an actual
sort of unified theory of nature
but there also isn't a
in my view some people would disagree
with me
but there isn't a reasonable
uh possibility that we would be able to
do an experiment in the foreseeable
future which would be sort of a yes or
no
to to string theory okay so you've been
there from the early days of string
theory you've seen his developments what
are some interesting developments uh
what do you see as the also the future
of string theory
and what is string theory
well the basic idea which emerged in
the early 70s
was that if you
uh
you take
uh the notion of a particle and you
literally
replace it by a little Loop of string
the strings are sort of softer
than than particles what do you mean by
softer
well you know if you hit a particle
if there were particle on this table a
big one and you hit it you might bruise
yourself sure
but if there was a string on the table
you would probably just push it around
and and the source of the infinities
in Quantum field theories that would
particles hit each other it's a little
bit of a it's a little bit of a
a jarring effect and and
um
I've never described it this way before
but it's actually scientifically
accurate but if you throw strings at
each other it's a little more friendly
one thing I can't explain is how
wonderfully precise will the mathematics
is that goes into describing String
Theory we don't just wave our hands and
throw strings around and you know
there's some very
um
compelling mathematical equations that
describe it now what was realized in the
early 70s is that if you replace
particles by strings these Infinities go
away
and you get a consistent
theory of gravity without
the infinities
and um
that may sound a little trivial but at
that point it'd already been
15 years that people had been searching
around for any kind of theory that could
do this and it was actually found kind
of
uh by accident
and there are a lot of accidental
discoveries uh in this subject
now at the same time it was believed
then that string theory was an
interesting sort of toy model
for putting quantum mechanics and
general relativity together
on paper
but
um
but that it couldn't describe some of
the very idiosyncratic phenomena
that pertain to our own Universe in
particular the form of so-called parity
violation
our world another term for the bar later
tonight uh yeah yeah parity violation so
so if you go to the bar and I already
got the renormalizable quantity and you
look in the mirror across the bar yes
the universe that you see in the mirror
is not identical
you would be able to tell if you show
your your your your your
the lady in the bar the photograph that
shows both the mirror and you there's a
difference if she's smart enough she'll
be able to to tell which one is the real
world and which one is you now she would
have to do some very precise
measurements
and if the photograph was too grainy it
might not be possible but it's as simple
as possible why is this interesting why
is it does this mean that there is some
um not perfect determinism or uh what
does that mean there's some uncertainty
no it's a very interesting feature of
the real world
that it isn't parody of invariant and
string theory it was thought could not
tolerate that
and
um then it was learned in the mid 80s
that not only could it tolerate that but
if you did things in the right way you
could
construct a world uh
involving strings that reconciled
quantum mechanics and general relativity
which looked more or less like the world
that
we live in
and now that isn't to say that string
theory predicted our world
it just meant that it was consistent
that the the hypothesis that string
theory describes our world can't be
ruled out from the get-go
it is also
the only
proposal for a complete theory that
would describe
our world
still
nobody will believe it
until there's some kind of
direct experiment and I don't even
believe it myself sure which is a good
place to be mentally as a physicist
right always I mean Einstein didn't
believe his own uh equations right with
the black hole okay well that money was
wrong about that but
you might be wrong too right uh so do
you think string theory is dead if you
were to bet all your money on
um no the future of strength I think
it's a
a logical error to think that string
theory is either right or wrong or dead
or alive
what it is is a stepping stone
and
an analogy I like to draw
is yangmil's theory
which I mentioned a few minutes ago in
the context of standard model
yangmail's theory was discovered by
Yangon Mills in the 50s
and they thought that the symmetry of
Yang and Mills
Theory
described the relationship between the
proton and the neutron that's why they
invented it
that turned out to be completely wrong
does however
describe everything else in the standard
model
and it had a kind of inevitability you
know they had some of the right pieces
but not the other ones sure they didn't
have it quite in the right context
and it had an inevitability to it and it
eventually sort of found its place
and it's also true of Einstein's
theory of general relativity you know he
had the wrong version of it in 1914 and
he was missing some pieces and you
wouldn't say that that his early version
was right or wrong he'd understood the
equivalence principle it understood
space-time curvature he just didn't have
everything I mean technically you would
have to say it was wrong
and technically you would have to say
Yang and Mills were wrong and I guess in
that sense
I would believe just
odds are
we always keep finding new wrinkles odds
are we're going to find new wrinkles and
strings Theory and technically what we
call String Theory Now isn't quite right
but we're always going to be wrong but
hopefully a little bit less wrong every
time exactly exactly
and I I would
you know bet the farm as they say do you
have a farm
I you know I say that much more
seriously because not only do I have a
farm but we just renovated it
so before I renovated better get the far
my wife and I spent five years
renovating it before I you were much
much looser with that statement but now
I really need something no no it really
means something and and I would bet the
farm on the um
on the uh guess that 100 years from now
String Theory will be viewed as a
stepping stone towards a greater
understanding of
of nature and and it would I mean
another thing that I didn't mention
about strings theory is of course we
knew that it
solved the Infinities problem and then
we later learned that it also solved
Hawking's puzzle about
what's inside of a black hole
and we
put in one assumption you get five
things out somehow you're doing
something right you know probably not
everything but you're you're you know
there's some good signposts and there
have been a lot of good signposts like
that
it is also mathematical toolkit and you
you've used it you've used it with
camera and Waffa uh maybe we can sneak
our way back from String Theory into
black holes yeah
um what was the idea that you and
Cameron Waffa developed with the
holographic principle and string theory
were we able to discover through through
this through string theory about black
holes or um
that connects us back to the reality of
black holes yeah so that is a very
interesting story I was
interested in black holes before I was
interested in String Theory I was sort
of a reluctance
string theorist in the beginning I
thought I had to learn it because people
were talking about it but you know once
I studied it I I grew to love it first I
did it in a sort of dutiful way these
people say they've claimed quantum
gravity I ought to read their papers at
least
and then the more I read them the more
interested I got and I began to see you
know they
they phrased it in a very clumsy way the
description of string theory was was
very clumsy and mathematically clumsy or
just mathematically yeah
it was all correct but
but
mathematically clumsy but it often
happens
that in all kinds of branches of physics
that
um people start working on it really
hard and they sort of dream about it and
live it and breathe it and they begin to
see inner relationships and
they see a beauty that
is really there they're not they're not
deceived they're really seeing something
that exists but if you just kind of look
at it you know you can't you can't grasp
it all in the beginning and and um
so
our understanding of string theory in uh
uh in 1985 was almost all about uh you
know
weekly coupled waves of strings
colliding and so on we didn't know how
to describe
a big thing like a black hole and so you
know in string theory of course we could
show that strings in theory and some
limit reproduced Einstein's theory of
general relativity
and corrected it but we couldn't do any
better with black holes
then
um
before my work with Quran we couldn't do
any better than Einstein and shortchill
had done
now
um one of the puzzles
um you know if you look at the
Hawking's headstone and also Boltzmann's
headstone and you
put them together you get a formula
for their really Central equations in
20th century physics I don't
think there are many equations that made
it to headstones
and they're really Central equations and
you put them together and you get a
formula for the number of gigabytes in a
black hole
now a short shelves description
the black hole is literally a hole in
space and there's no place to store the
gigabytes
and it's not too hard to and this really
was wheeler and beckenstein and
wheeler beckenstein and Hawking
to come to the conclusion that
if there isn't a sense
in which a black hole can store
some large number of gigabytes
that quantum mechanics and gravity can't
be consistent
we've got we got to go there a little
bit so uh so how is it possible when we
say gigabytes is there's some
information so black holes can store
information how is this thing that sucks
up all light and it's supposed to
basically be you know be super
homogeneous and boring how is that
actually able to store information where
does the store information on the inside
on the surface
uh where where's yeah and what's
information
I'm liking this ask five questions to
see which one you actually answer oh
okay I should try to memorize them and
answer each one in order just to answer
them I don't know I don't know what I'm
doing I'm desperately desperately uh
trying to figure it out as I go along
here so um Einstein's Black Culture
Schwartz black hole they can't store
information
stuff stuff goes in there and it just
keeps flying and it goes to the
singularity and it's gone
however
Einstein's theory is not exact
it has Corrections
and string theory tells you what those
Corrections are
and so you should be able to find some
way of some alternate way of describing
the black hole that enables you
to understand
where the gigabytes are stored
so what Hawking and beckenstein really
did was they showed that physics is
inconsistent
unless
a black hole can store an a number of
gigabytes proportional to its area
divided by four times
Newton's constant times Planck's
Constant and that's another wild idea
you said area not volume exactly
and that's the holographic principle the
universe is so weird and that's the
holographic principle that's called the
holographic principle that it's it's the
area we're just jumping around what is
the holographic principle what does that
mean well is that some kind of weird
projection going on what what the heck
uh well I was just before I came here
writing an introduction to a paper in
the first sentence was
the
as yet imprecisely defined holographic
principle
blah blah blah blah so nobody knows
exactly what it is
but roughly speaking it says just what
we were alluding to that
um
really all the information
that is in some volume of space-time can
be stored on the boundary of that region
so this is not just about black holes
it's about any any areas based on any
area space however we've made sense of
the holographic principle for black
holes
we've made sense of the holographic
principle for something which could be
called anti-decider space which
could be thought of as a giant as the
black hole turned into a whole universe
and
um we don't really understand how to
talk about the holographic principle for
either flat space which we appear to
live in
or
asymptotically the sitter space which
astronomers tell us we actually live in
as the universe continues to expand
so it's one of the one of the huge
problems in uh physics is to
you know apply or even formulate the
holographic principle for
more realistic
well black holes are realistic we see
them but um
yeah in in more General context so a
general statement of the holographic
principle what's the difference in flat
space and uh asymptotic decider space so
flat space is just an approximation of
like the world we live in so like uh uh
the sitter space at some time I wonder
what that even means meaning like
uh asymptotic over what okay so for
thousands of years
you know until the last half of the 20th
well sorry until the 20th century
um we thought space time was flat
can you elaborate on flat
well what do we mean by flat
well like the surface of this table
is is flat let me just give an intuitive
explanation surface of the table is flat
but the surface of a basketball
is curved
so the universe itself
could be flat like the surface of a
table or it could be curved like a
basketball which actually has a positive
curvature
and then there's another kind of
curvature called the negative curvature
and curvature can be even weirder
because
that kind of curvature I've just
described as the curvature of space
but Einstein taught us that we really
live in a space-time continuum
so we can have curvature in a way that
mixes up space and time
and that's kind of hard to visualize
because you have to step what a couple
of Dimensions up so it's hard to you
have to step a couple but even a
if you have flat space and it's
expanding in time
you know we could imagine we're sitting
here this room good approximation it's
flat but imagine we suddenly start
getting further and further apart then
space is flat
but it's expanding which means that
space time is curved
ultimates of all space time okay so
what's the what's the sitter in
anti-discellular space
the three simplest space times
are flat space time which we call
minkowski space time
and negatively curved space-time
anti-decider space
and positively curved space-time the
sitter space
and so astronomers
um think that
on large scales even though for
thousands of years we hadn't noticed it
beginning with Hubble
we started to notice that space time was
curved space is expanding in time means
that space time is curved
and the nature of this curvature is
affected by the matter in it
because matter itself
causes the curvature of space-time
but as it expands the matter gets more
and more diluted
and one might ask when it's all diluted
away
is space-time still curved
and astronomers believe they've done
precise enough measurements to determine
this
and they believe that the answer is yes
the universe is now expanding eventually
all the unit matter in it will be
uh expanded away but it will continue to
expand
because uh well they would call it the
dark energy Einstein would call it a
cosmological constant in any case that
the in the far future
matter will be expanded away and we'll
be left with empty decider space okay so
there's this cosmological Einstein's
cosmological constant that now hides
this thing that we don't understand
called Dark Energy what's dark energy
what's your best guess at what this
thing is
why do we think it's there
it's because of this it comes from the
astronomers
dark energy is synonymous with positive
cosmological constant
and
um
uh we think it's there
because the astronomers have told us
it's there
and
um
they they know what they're doing and we
don't know really really hard
measurement but they know they really
know what they're doing
and
we have no freaking idea why it's there
another big mystery another another
reason it's fun to be a physicist and if
it is there why should it be so small
why should there be so little why should
it have hit itself from us
why shouldn't there enough be enough of
it to substantially curve the space
between us and the moon why did there
have to be
such a
small amount that only the crazy best
astronomers in the world could find it
well can't the same thing be said about
all all the constants
all of the Kentucky said about gravity
can't that be said about the speed of
light
like why is the speed of light so slow
so fast so slow
relative to the size of the universe
can't it be faster
or no well the speed of Lights is a
funny one because you could always
choose units
in which the speed of light is one you
know we measure it in kilometers per
second and it's 100
86 000 or miles per second is 186 000
miles per second
and but if we had used different units
yeah then we could make it one but you
can make dimensionless ratios
so
um you know you could say why is the
time scale set by the expansion of the
universe so large compared to the time
scale of a human life or so large
compared to the time scale for a neutron
to Decay you know yeah I mean ultimately
you know the reference the tempo
reference frame here is a human life
maybe isn't that the important thing for
us uh descendants of Apes isn't that a
really important aspect of physics
like uh because we kind of experienced
the world we Intuit the World Through
The Eyes of
the these biological organisms I mean I
guess mathematics helps you escape that
for time but ultimately isn't that
how you wonder about the world
absolutely that like a human life yeah
time is only 100 years because if you
think of everything
um if you're able to think in I don't
know in billions of years
uh then maybe everything looks way
different
um maybe universes are born and die and
maybe all these physical phenomena
become much more intuitive that we see
at the Grand scale of general relativity
well that is one of the a little off the
track here but that certainly is one of
the nice things about being a physicist
is
you spend a lot of time thinking about
you know insides of black holes and
billions of years in the future and and
it's sort of uh
gets you away from the day-to-day uh
into into another fantastic
realm
um
but I was answering your question about
how there could be information in a
black hole yes so
Einstein only gave us
an approximate description and we now
have a theory that corrects it string
theory
and now sort of was the Moment of Truth
well when we first discovered String
Theory we knew we knew from the get-go
that string theory would correct what
Einstein said
just like Einstein corrected what Newton
said
um but we didn't understand it well
enough
to actually compute the correction to
compute how many gigabytes there were
and sometime in the early 90s
we began to understand the mathematics
of string theory better and better
and it came to the point where it was
clear that this was something we might
be able to compute
and it was a kind of Moment of Truth for
string theory because
if it hadn't given the answer
that beckenstein and
Hawking said it had to give for
consistency
String Theory itself would have
been inconsistent and we wouldn't be
doing this interview well that's a very
dramatic statement but yes uh that's not
the most that's not the most dramatic
thing
I mean okay that's very life and death
you mean like that that uh because
string theory was Central to your work
at that time is is that what you mean
well String Theory would have been
inconsistent yeah okay so let it be a
string theory would have been
inconsistent but those inconsistencies
can give birth to other theories like
you said the inconsistency right
something else could have happened yes
yeah it would have been a major a major
uh change in the way we think about
string theory if it and it was a good
thing that you know one supposition that
the world is made of strings solves two
problems not not one solves the infinity
problem and it solved the Hawking's
problem
and also the way that it did it
was very uh was very beautiful
um it it gave an alternate description
so
alternate description thing of things
are are uh
are very common I mean we could to take
a simple example this bottle of water
here is
90 percent full I could say it's 90 full
I could also say it's 10 percent empty
those are obviously the same statement
and they're it's trivial to see that
they're the same but there are many
statements that can be made in
mathematics and mathematical physics
that are equivalent
but might take years to understand that
they're equivalent
and might take the invention or
discovery of whole new fields of
mathematics to prove their equivalent
and this was one of those
we found an alternate description
of certain black holes and string theory
which we could prove was equivalent and
it was a description of the black hole
as a hologram
that can be thought of a holographic
plate
uh that could be thought of as sitting
on the surface of the black hole
and the interior of the black hole
itself sort of arises as a projection
uh or the near Horizon region of the
black hole arises as a projection
of that holographic plate so the two
descriptions were the hologram
the three-dimensional image and the
holographic plate
and the whole gram is what Einstein
discovered and the holographic plate
is what we discovered
and this idea that you could describe
things very very concretely in string
theory in these two different languages
of course took off and was applied to
many uh many different
many different contexts within string
string theory